leur absence des stations est une marque
de succès une centaine de trottinettes
électriques et 35 stations sont en
expérimentation à saint rémy les
chevreuse et chevreuse un complément aux
autres mobilité comme le train le bus et
le transport à la demande c'est plus
économique que les autres moins de
transport c'est beaucoup plus écologique
et en plus c'est enfin sa demande est
forte parce qu'un vélo a mis à
disposition comme un vélib du coup je
pense vraiment que c'est un bon de
transport qui est adapté mais peut-être
bien mais moi je vu mon âge
c'est par lequel dieu je prendrais pas
mais bon
pour les jeunes chez très bien à
l'origine une demande des habitants du
plateau de saint rémy et de magny les
hameaux communes voisines afin de
faciliter l'accès à la gare rer de saint
rémy on a pensé que effectivement ça
pourrait permettre de combler un petit
peu ce manque de mobilité pour le
dernier kilomètre ce qu'on appelle
toujours le dernier kilomètre quand on
arrive de soi de son travail soit pour
aller de son travail à son domicile de
son domicile à une activité qu'elle soit
sportive
de formation ou autre c'est lié à une
démarche aussi environnemental de
facilités de déplacement de
d'intermodalité avec tous les modes
moyen de transport et je pense qu'il
faut rien s'interdire aujourd'hui une
alternative à la voiture qui rend
pourtant certains habitants sceptique je
suis assez assez assez
inquiet sur le fait qu'on n'ait
lectrices beaucoup de choses et donc ça
veut dire plus de batterie et plus de
terreur pas des choses dont on parle
beaucoup en ce moment et je sais une
dérive qui ne me plaît pas du tout vous
verrez une trottinette à l'ancienne j'ai
pas encore bougé un peu mes pieds pour
pour lüthi voilà sans motorisation 100
sont quoi que ce soit l'expérimentation
supervisé par l'entreprise tire mobility
va se poursuivre durant les mois à venir
en cas de réussite auprès des habitants
et de modèle économique viable le
service sera définitivement adopté